that was a javascript program until
two years ago and
i enjoyed it actually but at that time i
tried
i'd like to make something else i
have done java for many years i thought
i start to dump down
i need some fresh spirit right and at
that time i had this nice title of
ibm distinguished engineer and once i
told
ibm that i'd like to work for microsoft
within one day i became an extinguished
engineer
that's really cool actually because that
means you're out
of the building within one day which
means you have time
till the end of the work contract to do
other stuff
so three months to learn
so what did i do during these three
months i watched
recordings from the chairs conference
actually
and i really liked them i thought one
day i want to be at this conference
but this conference is always sold out
right so i learned you have to talk
there that you can get this conference
of course
now the problem is i had nothing right
so i was a baby well we are still a baby
so i need at least two years to get some
material to talk about and i see
i hope today i have enough material to
talk about
so
what i did in this last two years now i
built a small team in zurich
in good microsoft tradition we have
feature teams now we're testers and
program managers
we are now a developers and
our focus is and that's what i found the
challenge that
hoped to stop my thumbing down we work
on online develop experiences so the
idea is
whenever you interact through a browser
with code
we'd like to have components for you
right so we have a toolkit of components
that allow to build coding experience in
the browser and i can show you some of
them
which are shipping today which
you might use or not right so for
instance when it comes to team software
right we have diff engines
that joey diffs we have the typescript
playground
at this point i'd like to ask how many
of you have heard of typescript
excellent how many of you have played in
the typescript playground
i hope we fixed that today how many of
you use typescript in
in a project we work on that
so the good thing is no typescript has
been open sourced last october
so it's really a typescript plus the
language server has been open source
and i think i highly recommend try to
play with the typescript playground to
learn what this language has to offer
for you
i think it uses some dirty words like
classes modules and even interfaces
three dirty words but the goal is really
to reduce develop stress
and that's was my passion since i
started
writing code right i like to reduce the
developer stress that's why
junit happened that's my patterns that's
why clips now we want to
liberate developers to have fun coding
so the typescript playground is yet
another component
that is built on our stuff okay i will
show you later briefly it's probably one
of the most powerful playgrounds with
refactoring support and all kinds of
good stuff
on azure when it comes to script editing
we are used and for that i'd like to
give you a quick demo that's the one
which uses most of our components
which uses in a workbench that you can
do coding of
an an app that can put in the that you
can put into
the marketplace what you can do and
that's pretty cool
for office 365
and that's the only time i do some
microsoft product stuff
but what you can do is
you can write extensions for excel or
word
in html5 okay and for instance here i
have
written one which allows me to bubble
the some
stock quotes right and that's the html
widget which is extension i say bubble
it will go to the net
and show me all the stock quotes that's
okay a dangerous exercise because it
might be negative but
it's not too bad today huh it's good so
anyway so that's what you show what you
can do but the point is not that the
point is
you can use html5 technology to to do
that and
the point is to try this out you can do
it all in the browser right that's the
point that's the scenario getting
started
you want to try something you do it in
the browser
deployed if you like it you can upgrade
to the full id and i can quickly show
you
what we can do in the browser
okay
i'm confused but that's fine
that's not it that's powerpoint
come on don't drive me nuts
here we go well okay it's a little bit
people view but at least it's big enough
so you see now that's the workbench it
uses many of our kind of of the toolkit
of developer components
and it shows this app is really html5
it has an html page which loads several
scripts which has some script logic
right in the script i have normal stuff
live
code validation
come on yeah you see squiggles all this
stuff
you have um reference searching
who uses this stuff right you get it in
place
you have refactoring
it's really challenging to do it in this
tight resolution
but you see a free factoring all this
kind of neat stuff
you have navigation help and so on right
you can navigate
to stuff
so it's it's pretty rich right it has
outlining steps and stuff right things
like that
so this just to show you right it's
pretty rich experience so we say even
for getting started experience you want
to be rich and you want to have
a good coding experience with all the
comfort develop
comfort used from a browser so enough
that's kind of the background
let's go over and talk about
what's behind it and how we grew into it
and our journey
actually started two years ago and we
have grown in three stages right and
the challenge is really how to to become
bigger and bigger
and the approach you try to use is what
i would call
extreme triple extreme programming right
which means we don't
use some technology on the until we
really need it
until it really hurts right we knew from
the beginning yes there's required yes
there's amd which is cool
but we want to lean back and say let's
wait till we really use it and then we
dive in right you want to feel the pain
and then feel good afterwards
so and that's the three stages no we
have kind of small when we grew
quickly to 50 000 lines of code a
hundred thousand and today we had two
hundred thousand lines of code which you
wrote ourselves plus test code
with all the libraries right this goes
much higher
what i found interesting for each of
these stages
we have some patterns that were relevant
to us
so yes i confess they cannot get fully
get away with patterns right
in the smaller stage we're really
concerned about modules classes
interfaces promises right how you manage
callbacks
interface i will talk more about that
sounds a bit strange
but interfaces are a powerful way to
tell others
what you expect and in particular
it helps to define the shape of things
and that's what i will show later
models and classes every project has to
think about which patterns they use for
that
in the small stage what is interesting
we only use about 10
of typescript because we had some
concerns right we were the first
adopters
of typescript um while we saw the
promise we were skeptical that we'll
lose
the goodness of javascript right as i
said no i transitioned from java
in java one technology developed was
we called jdojo which was a java
front-end to the dojo widgets
and while i liked it a lot in these
three months right that i learned all
the stuff
this javascript community produced i
learned i really don't want to have a
layer in between right i want to program
as close to javascript as possible right
i want to throw out closures whatever
so for this reason we are a little bit
concerned and in particular our hardcore
javascript members were three in the
beginning
they said we were highly skeptical right
why
why do you want to do that so we started
very slowly then we
rarely grabbed ramped up at this point
even after one year we had skeptics
so our xx asked why don't you go 100
typescript
i say well lots of blah blah but
typically no
two of my developers just resisted they
didn't want to do it because they still
thought
javascript f5 and so on is faster for
them
interestingly right we see today we are
200 which means
these two hardcore guys they transition
and i can't show a little bit
what's the story that led to that
so other patterns knowing the medium
size amd lazy loaded contributions
components dependence injection which is
really a java thing
i thought i will never use that i hope i
can rationalize
why we do something in java world to get
to better testability
so i wonder how many of you know
tabscript
okay so i want to do two minutes quickly
show
typescript in action and then go on
okay quick walkthrough it's in the
playground you can all try it out the
point is
left tab script write javascript and the
point is no
typescript is very close to javascript
right that's
what's really important to us because as
i said we don't want to have lots of
layers in between javascript you want to
appreciate the full power
of javascript so um quickly to show that
typescript is just javascript right if
you see that it's almost the same code
that's just drawn to the typescript
compiler
it adds optional types all right you can
type thing here and the cool thing is
it does type inferencing which means you
don't have to type everything because
it's really smart and
from a return value of a function
inverted type and so on to make it easy
for you
and many other nice tricks it has
classes
again very similar translation right to
use prototypes with the closure
and as i said you have all the other
coolness in the
in this playground you can do
refactorings intelligence all the stuff
that i showed before because it's the
same kind of
component that we use you can use a
multi-cursor and
whatever whatever you want right
okay so classes and of course there's
modules
i didn't like that too much okay
the modules and actually it's our own
editor right so
you see it around corners that's the
sign that is our code editor we had for
various reasons we like we like code
mirror a's and so on but there is a
reason we had to write our own
but you have modules
right the modules follow the standard
module pad and you have a closure and a
module object
it captures what you export and
as i said typescript is really close to
javascript
and you can even debug on at the
javascript level if you use typescript
but still in the beginning i had the
skeptics in my team as i said
so let's go back to that and
one interesting word i mentioned is uh
interfaces right so
i think kind of emulating some
interfaces
uh as a in javascript in normal ways
just doesn't make sense right because
interface are really something more
at the time before you run thing to do
express things and one of the wisest
sentences i made i guess in this gang of
four because i always program to an
interface not implementation so
interfaces
i always like what's interesting in in
typescript interfaces are much richer
than just
what you see here as a way to define the
shape of a class right that's a typical
uh interface to describe define the
shape of a class which signatures it
does have
it's still very useful right it's very
useful because it allows me to check
whether an implantation conforms to a
particle interface and we have called
many
stupid bugs thanks to interface with
this capability
the good thing is interface are very
powerful defined the shape of things
right so if you have an option or an
option bag an object you just can
describe the structure easily through an
interface
and to make that easy you can say what's
optional what's mandatory
and we also use this a lot for
describing json structures right if you
serialize
json structures from the server to the
client we have a typescript interface
that describes the structure what's
optional mandatory
when we get the json object after the
parse we capture the interface you have
intellisense to navigate through the
json structure
it's pretty powerful nice
uh interfaces can also express and can
be uh
can be invoked which means you can also
define the signature for callbacks in a
compact way right so that says you have
a measurement call back has the
signature or you can also
index them you can define how you access
an object and if you
what's the type of the uh the indexed
access is a string or number then you
can say what you return
again to the benefit once you do that
you get
intellisense and rich coding con coding
support
by the tool because the tool knows what
at a certain point what the type is
and very important you can use interface
to describe
the the shape of existing javascript
code
and that's very important because you
want to have tooling for jquery knockout
whatever all the cool libraries
that the community produced like i must
say one thing
at this point these three months that i
had time to really get into javascript
and the transition from child to
javascript was my hardest language
transition
right i transitioned from c plus plus
too small dark from small to
java now from java to javascript that
was the hardest one and the reason is
because the javascript is so productive
right they produce node.js they produce
libraries interesting patterns like the
model
model view control model model view
pattern and so on right so this was
really what made me
kind of swallow a lot to get up to speed
but without makes it very clear you need
to have a way to describe
all these existing libraries otherwise
you don't get the coding comfort that i
want
because one thing i want to keep from
java i want to keep the coding comfort i
had there
right i want intellisense i want
refactoring i want to find references
that's just i didn't want to lose
so now how to use that and the nice
example is
to use that for jquery
so that's kind of another playground
right once you have this toolkit of uh
coding components you can produce
playgrounds as you like and this
playground shows in the left
some type definition file that just
describes jquery on the right the sample
of jquery code
which should kind of it's a nice play
right on the left you can
add type definitions and then on the
right you can experience
how much how how richer your coding
experience gets right
like i can do the dollar stuff i get
intellisense
and we all know the nice method chaining
you can do with jquery right
and so on and that's thanks to all this
type deafness on the right and jquery is
very rich
when it comes to coding comfort right
they use lots of optional stuff
like for instance you know that's an uh
the interface to describe the
h the hx settings you see lots of stuff
is optional but you can still express
the structure get intelligence for it
promises right the promise the
consumer the deferred aspect which is
the provider
after the promise it's all captures
interfaces and once you do that you get
this powerful intelligence behavior in
the tool
which would be very hard to do otherwise
and let me just see how it's done
right jquery static captures the dollar
what you can do on the dollar
and one important thing you can do on
dollar is all these accesses through a
selector through an element
through a function and playing with
different things happen and this all can
be expressed through interfaces right
okay so if you have done that what the
powerful thing is
you can describe these libraries and you
get rich tooling support now it's even
better
there is a community now that does that
okay and the cool thing is
there's a whole project on github that
does these type definitions for all
the libraries right this is definitely
typed library github
and it's very active and almost for any
javascript library you will find
corresponding type definitions
and it's a very interesting look at them
because it really helps to expose
what are what actually do these
libraries really do because you get lots
of insights
when you see that and you get much more
inside than reading textual descriptions
right because it's really in the code
at hand let's see the next step so we
have grown up
um we have used typescript models
classes you have used promises i cannot
go in details which version we use the
problem is there are many words of
promises so you have to pick one
we picked one and of course other teams
pick other ones which we have to fund
then
when you combine the code we go to the
next level we grew up to 100 000 lines
of code
and we felt we're not health anymore
right i always liked
this metaphor of code fitness right when
when my code is fit i can run fast
my code isn't fit i get slow and we felt
that 100 sounds lines
we're not as fit anymore because we
cannot run that fast as you want
so what were the pains points we had
well the long list of scripts
peter higgins showed that we had the
same problem right not only you have to
manually this long list you have to also
have the right order
and so on something is wrong here
dependencies big problem right so module
pattern makes you feel like you have
modules but it's a very weak way
to express a dependency right because a
module is just an object and i can
easily add a property
they're always open i can contribute the
module from anywhere
without any constraints right
so and one of the things we noted is
that our javascript was rotting over
time
and the dependency graph looked really
messy actually this is a comment i
signed a mail from yesterday which is
not
from our project but it shows right
that's a problem right managing
dependencies in a large scale project
javascript project around 100 000 line
that hurts
so you need to do something against it
last but not least we had also growing
pains because
even though we had 100 000 lines of code
we don't want to load them on startup
right when you have tools you have lots
of optional stuff right when i
when i edit when i don't edit
a c-sharp file i don't want to load the
c-sharp
related code right i want to load it
only when you actually do something with
c-sharp
for instance so we had this problem
though we had the eagle loading our
network tab it's really ugly when you
see that that's always a good health
exercise look at
your network tab when you start your
application browser we looked really
ugly lots of requests
lots of data transfer very unhappy amd
to the rescue
we saw it already dojo did it wonder one
function rules at all
it's a very nice spec actually it's a
short spec one function
but a very rich one so in order to
understand it we had to implement our
own amd loader
and it was really good and we still use
our own loader because um
gives some flexibility but it's
conforming to the spec
so what does typescript offer to that
what's nicer typescript
they can abstract kind of the details of
the module definition from you
basically in typescript you can write an
external module statement that gives a
path to the location of the module
and then when you actually transpile it
to javascript
then you can decide which module system
you're using and depending on it will
generate different
required statements or define statements
for you so that's very nice
and we found that very handy because
this defined statement
can become hard to manage when you have
20
imports right you have to count all the
time and typescript makes it kind of
nicer but still we use both at time time
right we convert our code in javascript
and in typescript we work intensely with
the typescript team at this time to get
kind of
the support for the module systems in so
that we can really kind of
use them with comfort for what we did
the other challenge we have is you want
to support our card consumption
right so that's really nice with amd
because of amd the code knows its
dependencies
and we know we get many external
customers and they want to have
different pieces from our toolbox
so the nice thing with amd you can pull
out anything and thanks that each
thing knows its dependency you know we
get everything you need
one missing piece we found was css right
if you want to have self-contained
modules
you want that the css when you pull one
component out comes with it as well
so for this reason though but amd allows
you to support that too so we had an amd
loader plugin for css
which we also can hint to typescript
transpiler using a progma that tells
actually in this this class uses the css
class which includes the images and so
on
the cool thing about that is really have
these self-contained modules right
you can just pull them out if you don't
want a component you can drop but you
will not get it at all
okay that's also my favorite slide in
eclipse
the problem is how you scale up you have
lots of code and the pattern here is
lazy loading of contributions right
people contribute to you but of course
just because they contribute to you
doesn't mean you want to load it all and
what did it
wildly different at this time than an
eclipse
we still use this contribution pattern
by saying you split the contribution two
parts
one is the top of the iceberg the
visible part and the visual part is what
you always load
right the one which you need so that it
can function and
deal and play as if the component is
loaded
and what we do is we use javascript to
describe the component
javascript is very powerful so we didn't
want to use xml
and we like javascript much better
because of intellisense or validation
whatever
so um here we describe the component in
this case it's the c-sharp
language mode language service it says
load it when you load a file of type
c-sharp
you describe which module to load and
which class to instantiate
right that's how it works and that's
kind of the tip of the iceberg
and once a file of this type is loaded
then
the code below is loaded thanks to the
amd require call that allows your low
code dynamically
and we can then load lots lots of code
only on demand when needed right
this is how we can scale up and and use
it in many places right if some
we have used different views we only
know the use when
the first time become visible we don't
build them up front and thanks to the
self containers of css and everything
together
everything comes with a contribution in
one swoop
what was interesting after this
migration it was hard though i must say
this took us
two months to migrate our code because
well
yeah it was a little bit the
dependencies were messy we had to remove
many cycles we had also organized a
directory structure
which i found is a common problem in
large javascript project right
directory structure is kind of random
but the good thing is afterwards and
kind of all
alex is our hardcore developer he says
he really feels like fresh showered
and that's a good sign and we also felt
we can run fast again
our fitness was good again and we can go
on right we have
no more cycles no more globals and
everything with explicit dependencies
you feel good after that well we have
still grown further right
as usual and in particular softer tools
they will always grow
and now comes the next step to 100
typescript
uh what did you do there so we are into
other limitations
the first one was our hardcore
javascript programmer felt
he really starts to feel like writing
javascript canonical feels like
carving code in stone but he wrote the
editor
and he really felt when he wants to
refactor and javascript had a hard time
and he had
to refactor a property called id and
teacher said i die
unless i really know where this is used
precisely
so he asked me can i have this can i
have time to convert
the attitude type script and by this in
this way we got from 50
to 100 percent so this was the
growing pain right that we could really
we lost our agility to change code
uh tooling slow down because you know we
transplant lots of code
200 000 lines even a fast compiler takes
a while
and you also find this coupling thing
our testability went down
because some of our high level objects
they have dependencies on depends on
services when you write a test
you have to instantiate lots of other
objects right
and this is really kind of this java
pattern of dependence injection that
allows you from the outside to inject
different implementation of services so
they control what is instantiated and
you can also
get a lot of configuration config
configuration flexibility
so okay that's a slide so it just get a
feel that clean up
from when we went went to 100 typescript
we got a kind of a speed of 300 lines of
code per hour which is not a lock
but it's explained because you really
clean up stuff right you describe
objects you add
interfaces to capture the structure you
use and you were a highly disabled
developer he found no
as he just uses objects in javascript he
uses different formats
and he wasn't consistent but once he
could express the structure
the objects they had if he flows around
his system he could make it consistent
that was a cool thing componentization
is another thing right at some point you
say well we don't want to have
all the code read it like it's our
source code i just work with it i don't
i use it
but i don't need to change it right and
you need to have some way of
componentization which means it treated
as a binary component
unfortunately typescript supports that
and this is how you use the typescript
compiler for instance we treat it as
a binary component that we just slurp in
as
javascript code without having to
recompile it every time and there's a
compiler option that allows you to
generate these declarations
the interfaces that capture the shape of
the
classes in this component
dependence injection i don't want to
talk too much about that
it's somehow helped us because now we
found we'd use kind of some common
services and we don't want to
instantiate that so we identify the
services
create interfaces for them and then we
inject them
into the code for some high level
objects
last point just as i speak the
typescript team is actually working
eagerly on getting that 0.9 release out
which is a very important milestone for
them two with one o
and the big achievements in this release
is the added generics
which makes you gives you more power to
describe things
like for instance you can describe the
map function right the map function is
interesting
because you pass in a function which
returns
a value and the resulting type
of the array depends on the return value
of the function and now you can describe
that
in typescript so which means you get
richer intelligence even in this case
and the compilers in your architecture
which should make it scale better for
very large projects
so our retrospective we were skeptical
initially even though we also microsoft
we're very skeptical because we didn't
want to lose the javascript
feel we didn't want to use the
javascript closeness
but in the end i think it paid out for
us we feel we are
we fit again we can run fast so we would
do it again
and in fact this time we would start a
typescript
and amd from the beginning so that's our
conclusion and
my point here is really this is open
source give it a try
it helped us to increase our developer
comfort
i hope maybe it helps you too okay thank
you
you